hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master mandar go from Thailand
Ezra Massa get Sheila friend of mine for
a teammate and he decided to go for
brilliant weather in Thailand instead of
cool to Germany well today we've got
good weather but still it's probably
better in Thailand yeah so this is not
his regular repertoire but he sometimes
plays this line yeah he's got a very low
rating for his standards usually he's
operating on 24 to 25 so kind of
surprising to see so what about this
yeah night to age five it's a it's
sometimes an issue here in this position
hmm taking one g3 is probably not a
great idea
soulkey five maybe prevent night h5 for
the moment
yeah this is this line here with the
with the pawns is the double pawns is
slightly annoying for black it's very
difficult to do anything ever and in
some cases you have even have to be
somewhat alert not to be worse okay so
what about this here night comes to h5
look III night h5 I don't have a clear
answer to that move that's a bit it's a
bit lame here right h5 Bishop e7 whom
probably didn't played well
yeah well you can probably aside I
definitely didn't play it well what
would seem so the aiming for c4 here I
don't know maybe okay so maybe he wants
to double okay before it gets a super
annoying pin I'm going to allow the
trade here or not allow encourage the
trade check
ed looks passive for black but Jack it's
still very difficult for him to to do
something serious to me and this that's
my experience with those positions one
thing is definitely clear like it
stopped going to win this is it is
clearly clearly not happening okay so
group g3 ice at the point
okay i see that i get i need to get rid
of some ponds and I think that rook
before can be a useful counterplay like
roof g3 I take on b3 and play loop for
so here Bishop age 7 is just a check so
or threatens just a check here I thought
rook before so after Luke g7 I have Luke
checks f4 isn't that something
or does he have something I mean okay g7
rue care for you can continue to play
this position just play rook h7 or
something now that's definitely possible
don't know if it's dangerous though yeah
and i don't know i don't think it's easy
for y to do much him
Bishop h7 yeah I just I was just about
to say that this could be something but
well Bishop c7 blunders appear so but if
you checks me I go to e7 the issue is
that this is unprotected cell and okay
maybe can take one f4 cannot cope you
should see sound
ok I'm going to move that maybe he can
play this intake of success but I
thought rook F for cocaine
hmm
hmm I don't know c5 so Missy three-time
warning ok threatening to take this now
and promote Bishop a4 would threaten to
take it again this is hanging ok I'll go
back first check
I don't have a square damn I thought I
thought I can play Bishop f2 what edge I
have a decent decent square available
check check check check and we have no
time I have no time whatsoever Jack I
simply didn't didn't look at the clock
not sure might be lost might be a draw
but okay yeah it's kind of kind of fun
exciting in this position why there's
just shuffling around forever and he
should never really win but um I have
played it badly and here here why this
was of course but I couldn't couldn't
get it couldn't get it to work just
threaten to capture it check this is
what the engine is giving a slight
advantage for black threatening this
javed I cannot cannot make much all of
this
rook b-2s better maybe winning the sea
porn and where this is what I played f5
I can also give the check first maybe
this is stronger like this and this
that's what we had right hmm I don't
know I to do do do something in
positions where I should probably just
make a draw because of the time when you
have more time actually where did I
spend all the time yeah I round here
check yeah I should go look g 6 i'm
currently really not playing well I'm
the time pressure i play really badly
check this is still very ok check check
check yeah ok this this doesn't make any
sense any water and the last because I
will lose that on time yeah I have a bad
time management at the mood and don't
play well in critical positions I also
spend too much time you at the beginning
of this should just play quicker may I
try to find some ideas but there is no
idea there is no idea check check
yeah yeah I got a chip message that had
Bishop f2s there but it didn't work him
check the maid I saw that it was
something that I had plenty when I gave
the check I actually thought that we
should be to what song but it isn't it
isn't yeah yeah anyway thanks for
watching